when we were writing the screenplay for
the Black Russian we wanted to draw on
real life issues that are happening in
that part of the world and one of the
biggest issues over there is not only
the drugs but how politicians and the
police themselves are involved in the
whole process so in our film when the
protagonist the call on the lawyer goes
to india to look for his fiancee he
comes across those very same issues
where the police force the politicians
are inclusion with these narco
terrorists and it becomes a very
interesting compelling story because you
you have this guy who already is no
foreign land and he's going to hold the
proper sources to get help but they are
the actual help is is not the help
they're actually the enemy so we we we
use those real-life elements that we've
seen happen in that part of the world
and transpose them onto our screenplay
and and use it to tell this story did
art imitate life in any sense when you
were over there did you encounter anyone
trying to stop you or any resistance
well we were shooting in the North
northern region of India which borders
Pakistan so it's an area that is under
heavy surveillance from the indian army
so we had a lot of indian army personnel
around and it was you know our line
producers told the crew like you know
after you know certain amount you know
after dark make sure you back at the
hotel and so forth so although the
setting was safe we didn't have any
incidents you definitely felt the
presence of the army and you and you
kind of got a feeling of that the area
wasn't as you know pristine as one would
one would think if you just looked at
the scenery how did you conduct yourself
and how did you advise the other staff
members or excuse me crew members to
conduct themselves I mean just was it
not to make eye contact will most be
incredibly respectful or not even
engaged no I I actually told the crew I
said look you you're here in India you
go out and have a good time you know go
out there meet people explore do what
you got to do but you know
stay in a group and just be back before
a certain time and whenever you're going
anywhere make sure you take one of our
local guys with you so I encourage them
to actually meet people and talk to
people and not to be standoffish because
there were a lot of tourists in the area
as well and just you know be smart about
it you know go in groups and and also
use the resources that we have like the
drivers and so forth and explore
you